Thế thuốc sửa lại bà để sửa liên tục phải đất nhận sét để sửa đông thắp.
Thế với trở sông nghiệm đi tìt được một sửa đông thắp và phải khẳng liên tầy nơi.
Đi nó bệnh tìa họ.
Nhân, sét bề một cái đề thì, có nghĩa trụ thông thì đai nó một tìa họ.
Thế chào tìa nó bệnh tìa tụi và tìa khó.
Cem có thể đổ khó ngay từ hạ cầu tiền ở lại khó hơn sau đó đi chừng tưởng tưởng tưởng.
Thông tưởng, các bạn tổng chân cái lủng sài nó cũng lành phải tổng thó luôn.
Tập về ra trong người khác và phòng thì.
Nó tất nhiệm lúc bệnh quá khó măng gặng nấu, nhưng mà sét chừng mặt bằng chung và trung sài thì các bạn tổng đây đều có thể tổng thó.
Đặc biệt, nào ký câu âm số của cây mụ nó kìa cơm và tất cả phó chị.